[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
nous sommes en direct au coeur du centre
ville de dijon à la brasserie des loges
et ses deux centres villes que nous
allons parler des centres villes qui
agite beaucoup la vie municipale entre
les villes qui piétonniser qui
repoussent les voitures et celles qui
cherchent des solutions parfois pour
faire vivre leur coeur y compris en
redonnant de la place à la voiture en
terrasse avec nous nathalie koenders
bonjour bonjour lilian melet première
adjointe au maire de dijon dijon qui a
entamé cette semaine une nouvelle phase
de piétonnisation à deux pas d'ici
denis thuriau bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le maire de nevers nevers longtemps
classée dans les centres villes en
difficulté
vous avez fait de parler de vous avec
des mesures parfois radicales
denis favier bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le président de shop in dijon la
fédération des commerçants et les
artisans dijonnais on parle beaucoup de
ce sujet ces derniers temps il ya bien
sûr le dossier des voies sur berge à
paris concerne beaucoup de villes
nathalie koenders je le disais dijon
entame une nouvelle phase de
piétonnisation alors bêtement pourquoi
piétonniser parce que c'est une mode
est ce que c'est une nécessité est ce
que c'est irréversible c'est déjà une
forte demande de la part des habitants
aujourd'hui la piétonnisation est
largement plébiscité j'ai eu l'occasion
d'animer une réunion avec les riverains
qui sont concernés par la piétonnisation
du square des ducs
ils attendent vraiment cette
piétonnisation parce que ça se traduise
ça traduit une baisse de la pollution
atmosphérique une baisse des nuisances
sonores et donc une meilleure qualité de
vie et en même temps c'est aussi bon
pour le développement économique puisque
ça permet de créer des boucles de
cheminements piétons et puis d'avoir un
centre ville plus attractif et la preuve
en est ici puisque sans piétonnisation
nous pourrions pas aujourd'hui débattre
sur cette terrasse place du théâtre ça
pour ceux qui le sont pas à dijon c'est
historiquement y avait pas de place ici
il y avait une rue denis thuriau mode
nécessité ces mêmes questions ou danger
quand on est maire d'une ville moyenne
c'est un peu les deux donc il faut
maîtriser un peu les choses en parle
aussi avec les commerçants qui sont
assez partagés sur la question et
surtout ne pas faire peur et je le vois
nevers cosne et ils profond de politique
de rénovation que je m'étais promis
d'engager et notamment un certain nombre
de rues
en cette veille de 14 juillet qu'ils
n'étaient pas piétonne connaît
aujourd'hui une autre vieille des
terrasses un peu dans le même esprit qu
ici donc c'était nécessaire mais ça
avait été travaillé en amont il ya
d'autres endroits où je vais faire les
travaux il va pendant ces travaux
profiter d'une période test
et puis on verra pragmatiquement si
handicapant pour le commerce y au
contraire cela le relance faut tenir
compte aussi des prêts matic d'accès de
riverains voilà il faut essayer de
concilier les choses alors on va on va
essayer d'approfondir sa denis favier le
mot commerçant a été prononcée à
plusieurs reprises
historiquement dans les années 70 quand
on voulait piétonniser souvent les
commerçants étaient contre parce qu'il
avait l'habitude que les gens se garent
devant chez eux
est-ce que les mentalités ont évolué et
est ce que c'est toujours quand même
compliqué quand on est commerçant et
qu'on apprend que la rue devant chez soi
elle doit être canonisé oui bien sûr
c'est toujours compliqué mais il ya une
évolution de la consommation
une évolution de la société il faut je
pense conjuguer tout ça nous avons
besoin de ces zones piétonnes nous
avions effectivement à dijon de zones
piétonnes un petit peu séparés par une
rue encore passante
ça ça va être comblé donc on va avoir un
grand plateau ici en centre ville
et puis effectivement il y aura
maintenant un vrai cheminement à la fois
pour dijonnais pour celui qui vient
depuis la bourgogne et puis pour le
touriste donc il ya une véritable
évolution et le commerçant on a quand
même besoin
est ce que c'est et c'est une question
que je vous pose à tout d'abord une
problématique de grandes villes voire de
très grandes villes et pas de villes
moyennes
nathalie koenders est ce que vous
pourriez ne pas piétonniser dijon par
exemple
non je pense que c'est aussi une
responsabilité qu'on se doit vis-à-vis
de les citoyens et non responsabilité
environnementale et écologique
à l'instar des grandes villes
européennes et des grandes villes de
france où c'est vrai que on doit
réfléchir sur un espace public mieux
partagée entre le piéton la voiture les
transports en commun savez vous parliez
dans les années 70 tout était fait
autour de la voile à adapter la vie de
la voiture vous avez adapté
effectivement maintenant il faut
repenser l'espace public pour autant
pour nous il n'est pas question que le
centre soit plus accessible aux voitures
d'ailleurs nous avons aussi par qui se
faisait un peu reproché avec le tarif
des stationnements
alors ça c'est un autre débat on peut en
parler mais nous avons dix parkings
souterrains nous avons huit mille places
de stationnement en ouvrage
donc l'objectif c'est aussi de changer
les habitudes et que les personnes qui
viennent en centre ville si elles
doivent rester longtemps et bien
privilégier les past and marshall
tétanisation que s'il ya ça que s'il ya
des places de stationnement que s'il ya
des accès ah oui je pense qu'on doit
quand même travaillé bien sûr sur
l'accessibilité en voiture en transport
commun en commun et aussi
l'accessibilité concernant les
livraisons alors denis quirion quand
vous avez vous êtes devenu maire de la
ville on sait que le ver était dans l'
entre guillemets la liste rouge des
villes qui avaient des vacances
commerciales les plus élevés c'est à
dire des boutiques non occupés est ce
qu'on peut dire à ses commerçants quand
on est dans cette situation je vais
piétonniser des rues en plus j'en veux
dire que ça va un peu mieux presque sont
les chiffres qui le disent on allait
plus de 24% de vacances commercial ce
qui est énorme
un moyenne 6 autour de 14% en france
aujourd'hui on semble être passé si
tenté que les chiffres soient plus mon
fiable à moins de 20% il ya plus de
commerces qf que deux commerces qui
ferment maintenant combat n'est pas
gagné non plus hein je le dis avec
humilité passer encore beaucoup de
choses à faire mais je pense que c'est
tout un ensemble de leviers auxquels
j'avais travaillé et est tant mieux
d'ailleurs qui vont être en parlera sans
doute mais repris dans le cadre du
programme action coeur de ville alors
après l'objectif de la piétonnisation
construit des villes
gypa médial parce que jugée plutôt
médiane que moyenne parce que moyen ça
fait un peu comme à l'école on est du
bon ni mauvais médian mairie d'avoir
médian et gyan mais disons 2000
habitants en quoi voilà la question
centrale est mais voilà trente quarante
mille huit cent cinquante mille fois la
même chose sur les années en agglo
l'agglo fait 72 mille aujourd'hui le
coeur de ville ce que je préfère dire le
coeur c'est ce qui bat le coeur de ville
qui doit continuer passé le coeur de
l'agglo et ça faut que tous les élus en
soit conscient donc ce choeur là il faut
à la fois réfléchir avec l'innovation
parce qu'on va pas du tout avoir la même
approche des commerçants quelques années
mais ya une palette de transition
abordés l'objectif il est même cas que
dans une grande ville comme dijon il est
d'apaiser les choses par contre son ex
sur personne et à nevers on n'a pas le
luxe de dire il ya plus de voitures on
n'a pas le même qu'à passer transports
en commun même si on améliorer le réseau
on a une course in hell électrique
maintenant on a voulu vraiment montrer
qu'on est s'inscrivait dans une
politique de développement durable
par contre faut du parking et faut
orienter les gens vers ce parking
alors j'ai fait un choix très différents
c'est ça moi j'ai pris la gratuité puis
le 1er janvier tout est gratuit donc
vous faites circuler des voitures dans
nos verres donc vous n'êtes pas très
copains 21
en stationnement surface et j'ai aménagé
encore d'autres zones au mois de mai
tout le coeur de ville de nevers devient
zone 20 zone de partage
ça veut dire quoi priorité via le vélo
vélo peut arriver piétons voilà et les
voitures doivent faire attention aux
autres il ya notamment des nouvelles
rues qui n'ont plus de trottoirs donc il
faut pas qu'ils aient de louper ce
serait une approche pour ville médiane
peut-être oui saison de partage mais je
suis très conscient que ce que je fais
c'est sans doute valable pour quelques
années parce que je les ai en période
transitoire donc des grandes zones
bleues vers les commerces pour la
fluidité de deux heures sauf des
commerces où il ya besoin d'une plus
courte période et le reste parce que
faut aussi penser aux riverains des
zones blanches où ils ont délaissé le
délai légal de 7 jours mais ce que je
fais c'est que je prépare demain dans ma
réflexion des aménagements publics de
l'espace public est dommage et plus
testé notamment à jérusalem dans
d'autres villes c'est le véhicule au
tome qui est prêt la législation va
évoluer dès cette année j'en ai discuté
avec la mise et transport isabelle borne
donc je pense moi des futurs
aménagements ou les voitures déposeront
les consommateurs et les promeneurs dans
le centre-ville
et s'ils iront se garer donc y aura plus
le même besoin d'approcher le véhicule
qu'aujourd'hui une question aussi sur la
piétonnisation denis favier est ce que
les commerçants de centre ça est-ce que
la piétonnisation ça remplace pas dans
les centres villes les habitants par les
touristes non non non je suis pas du
tout convaincu on l'entend parfois en
disant finalement les habitants de la
ville ne viennent plus dans le centre
mais les touristes ils sont nombreux ça
profite à l'économie aux entreprises aux
commerçants mais est ce que c'est une
sorte de remplacement non il n'y a pas
de remplacement d'abord on a des
résidents centre ville de dijon il faut
qu'on les garde il faut que justement
tout ce monde cohabite que ce soit les
résidents les commerçants et touristes
on a de plus en plus de touristes à
dijon depuis entre autres avec le
classement à l'unesco on l'a beaucoup
remarquée déjà l'an dernier puisque en
juillet en août mois j'ai beaucoup de
commerces et pas que des commerces de
souvenirs mais beaucoup de commerces qui
ont fonctionné grâce aux touristes
donc il faut que tout ce monde
cohabitent et pour venir aussi aux modes
de transport il faut que tous les modes
de transport cohabitent en centre ville
est entre autres chez nous en
centre-ville de dijon
il faut réussir à faire venir les
dijonnais au centre-ville zalik enders
et qui est pas que les touristes canton
piétonniser alors ce que c'est ça la
difficulté
oui moi je voudrais juste rebondir parce
que nous
on a aussi des fois des demandes de
stationnement gratuit au centre ville je
pense que nos centres villes ne sont pas
comparables même si on a voilà les les
mêmes objectifs
j'ai discuté il ya quinze jours avec le
maire de tours qui a dû parce que le
forfait fps avait été mal mis en place
il a dû pendant une semaine met le
stationnement gratuit sur toulouse il a
dit c'est catastrophique ne fait surtout
pas ça plus de places de parking au
centre ville les voitures qu'on appelle
tampon et elle a donc nous vraiment
l'objectif c'est vraiment de de faire un
turnover
après la piétonnisation justement elle
encourage les gens à venir habiter au
centre ville parce que comme je les dis
c'est une meilleure qualité de vie une
baisse de la pollution atmosphérique
mais on la compagne aussi il ya tout eu
une phase où nous allons retravailler
sur la rénovation de l'habitat c'est à
dire rue de la liberté on lance une
rénovation de façade pour voir aussi si
on peut re a réhabilité les premiers
étages et puis c'est aussi des
opérations de logements qu'on fait aux
portes du centre ville près du tramway
qui sont à moins de cinq minutes en
transport en commun ça dégage des
espaces et ça dégage des espaces pendant
24 heures la piétonnisation aussi on
parle souvent des espaces d'urnes et des
espaces nocturne
il ya cette dimension là aussi quand
même que d'un seul coup il ya des zones
vides qui reste vide qui sont vides la
nuit et qui peuvent poser des soucis ou
pas on en tient compte de sa glace et à
nous aussi de le travailler avec
l'aménagement urbain et puis le travail
et aussi parce que c'est c'est aussi une
force des centres-villes de la
convivialité donc mettre en place des
animations pour justement et bien qu'on
ait un centre ville attractif avec les
commerçants sont aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
il ya des animations sont prévues mais
la titrisation permet justement de faire
ces animations en sécurité vous faites
ça dans une zone qui malheureusement
n'est pas piétonne vous êtes obligé de
mettre des bornes en béton etc
alors que là dans ce secteur sauvegardé
et piétons vous pouvez faire des
animations en toute sécurité comme cet
après midi on le sait denis favier
nouveaux commerçants ils sont d'accord
là dessus que
c'est pas mauvais pour le commerce les
zones piétonnes parce que c'est une
espèce de tarte à la crème qu'on entend
tout le temps on ferme ce dossier là
avant de passer à la suite dans les
missionnaires mais c'est ce qu'il pense
au départ je pense oui effectivement on
va tous piétonniser va y avoir des
problèmes d'accessibilité etc
mais une fois que la piétonnisation est
réalisé et que quelques mois se sont
écoulés
croyez moi ils sont quand même content
parce que vous ne vous pouvez faire du
lèche vitrine d'ailleurs plus en
sécurité qu'auparavant avec les bus qui
passent les voitures sur des micro
trottoirs comme ça va être le cas par
exemple dans ce prolongement de la rue
des forges
ce sont deux tout petits trottoirs les
gens ne peuvent pas déballé ils ne
peuvent pas mettre de portant sur le
trottoir et du coup les gens ne
regardent même pas les vitrines à
l'heure actuelle ça ça va être évolutif
et c'est ce qui est bien et ça a permis
de travailler sur l'accessibilité des
commerces passé grâce à la
piétonnisation il vient de claquer en
fait sont rendus accessibles
absolument alors peu pardonnez moi
j'aimerais y avoir une autre piste aussi
que je tente depuis quelques temps avec
mon équipe à la vie de nos verts savent
que nous piéto disons partiellement et
temporairement des autres notamment les
soirs où sont pas des rues qui doivent
être piétonniser à la journée sinon ça
peut être pénalisant pour certains
commerces par contre pour les activités
de restauration dans fin de journée
c'est piétonniser jusqu'à 2 heures du
matin et il ya des commerces qui du coup
notamment de restauration qui ont
embauché voir qu'ils ont si je puis dire
sauver leur peau grâce à cela donc il ya
parfois des moyens aussi
d'individualiser les solutions alors la
piétonnisation n'est qu'un aspect d'un
dossier plus vaste et plus complexes qui
sont les difficultés des centres villes
je le disais tout à l'heure en
présentant l'émission gouvernement a
annoncé la semaine dernière à un blanc
action au coeur de ville de 5 milliards
pour 222 villes françaises dijon n'y est
pas parce que dijon n'est pas dans la
catégorie des moyennes des villes
moyennes voilà où médias n'en faisaient
entendre à denis thuriau alors on avait
beaucoup parlé de nos verres on lisait
tout à l'heure sur ce critère de la
vacance commercial en fait vous vous
êtes en première ligne dans ce dossier
vous faites partie des maires qui ont
travaillé en réalité sur ce dossier sur
ce qu'on pouvait faire pour aider les
centres villes tout à fait je vois
jacques mézard mercredi matin et son
directeur de cabinet mercredi après-midi
sur la la mise opérationnelle du plan
puisqu'il était lancée et c'est vrai que
j'avais eu la chance moi pendant ma
campagne en 2013 au travail est vraiment
parce que c'est une des priorités mais
aussi une des nécessités pour nos verts
de se relancer
compte tenu des contraintes vous avez
rappelé des difficultés antérieures donc
je suis très heureux qu'on s'intéresse
aux villes médiane et c'est pas du tout
un combat contre les métropoles on a
besoin des métropoles en europe et en
france et dans la mondialisation qui
existe par contre il ya tous ces
territoires entre les métropoles et puis
les campagnes qui sont des villes
médiane ses 25 26 % de l'emploi de la
population il n'y a rien eu depuis 1975
donc très content et elle rit faut quoi
il faut des mesures spécifiques ou des
choses qui concernent aussi nathalie
koenders et et denis favier
on vous vous allez travailler par
exemple sur les espaces commerciaux
vacants et sur l'idée de taxer par
exemple c'était un exemple à nevers
est-ce qu'il faut des choses coercitives
dans ce qu'il faut des textes pour aider
les villes moyennes ou est ce qu'il faut
de l'argent pour vous aider à créer un
moyen mais presque les textes ésident à
tous et nos villes ne sont pas opposés
les problématiques peuvent être
variables ont parlé du stationnement je
dis pas que ce que je fais d'abord c'est
un test n'est pas forcément la panacée
c'est un choix de relance avec par
contre des grandes zones bleues pour
éviter les voitures tampons parce que ça
c'est un vrai souci
par contre ce qu'on a mis en place comme
l'incitation fiscale parce
qu'effectivement tout ce qu'ils oublient
de s'occuper de leur local qui le loue
très cher c'est un obstacle
ça fait des vitrines vides au milieu des
vitrines occupés et ça c'est pas bon
pour les commerçants qui eux arrivent à
s'en sortir donc on avait décidé de
salles surtaxation sais pas ce n'est pas
le but de monter un projet plutôt
baissière mais là c'était pendant deux
ans j'ai été d'être gentil de décrire la
cité ça ne marchait pas au moins ça
provoque des réactions et les gens s'ils
n'ont pas un bon motif pour quoi ils ne
louent pas eh bien ils sont pénalisés
sur la taxe foncière et du coup j'ai
vérifié que récemment il y avait des
locaux qui ne trouvait pas preneur
depuis 15 ans qui ont retrouvé preneur
ça peut être des choses simples comme
l'habillage des vitrines vides on
réintéresse à des locaux et les gens les
preds on l'a constaté sur une place qui
était vide depuis 15 ans ça peut être
des choses très simples est ce que je
trouve intéressant dans le programme
action coeur de ville
c'est qu'on n'attend pas qu'on lance des
choses forcément nouvelle halle aux vins
inclure aussi les initiatives déjà
lancées et surtout il est individualisé
et c'est vrai qu'on a été quelques
maires parce que je sais à misrata ville
de france à contribuer à ce programme
book i les remontant n'est pas
descendant depuis paris alors nous
sommes je vous le rappelle ici
place du théâtre à dijon à la brasserie
des loges pour parler
des centre-ville et de la piétonnisation
nathalie koenders
vous n'êtes pas dans les guides médiane
mais ce sujet par exemple c'était une
grande tendance à un moment de voir
s'installer des banques partout dans un
certain nombre d'endroits
alors c'est souvent beaucoup plus
complexe que ça comme sujet mais c'est
l'impression que les gens en se
promenant dans la rue qu'elle est là la
marge la souplesse pour un maire ou un
bon première adjointe de l'intervenant
dire là dessus parce que finalement les
commerces ils font ce qu'ils veulent
dans une ville 1 c'est qu'on n'est pas
dans les villes médiane on a un taux de
vacance qui est très faible à dijon
hacker de 8% donc en inférieur à la
moyenne nationale pour autant ça veut
pas dire qu'il ne faut pas agir alors
par exemple avec l'histoire des banques
il y avait un outil un peu une épée de
damoclès dont on disposait c'était la
déclaration d'intention d'aliéner enfin
le droit de préemption qu'on pouvait
faire si une banque s'installait bon
aujourd'hui elles sont elles ont changé
leur façon de se développer les banques
ont appuyé ce problème et pourrait
plutôt avoir tendance à fermer les
agents pas là nous justement les leviers
c'est l'habitat où il faut qu'on
travaille pour faire de l'habitat
accessible à tous dans les coeurs de
ville et la ville de dijon a travaillé
dans ce domaine c'est aussi les services
parce que la spécificité d'un centre
ville par rapport à un centre commercial
si on veut les comparer c'est aussi
maintenant ce que je suis il ya des
services
il ya de la convivialité donc il faut
aussi travailler sur amener des emplois
ou centre-ville à dijon c'est plus de
2500 emplois et ça va continuer puisque
on a travaillé notamment en lien avec la
poste pour faire venir des lieux de
coworking pour des jeunes entrepreneurs
qui cherchent donc là ça crée de
l'emploi sacré de la vie
et puis enfin travailler sur sur les
services donc c'est nous il ya des
services publics en coeur de ville où on
adapte les horaires pour que les gens
aient bien viennent au centre ville pour
voir un médecin avoir besoin d'un
service public et en même temps mais un
consomme
vous pouvez faire mieux que lui pour
cent de vacances commercial ou c'est une
sorte de seuil un peu incompressibles on
peut toujours faire mieux maintenant on
est vigilant c'est vrai aussi qu'on a
une autre spécificité à dijon et c'est
une bonne chose c'est qu'on a un centre
ville
sauvegardez qui n'a pas été détruit
pendant la guerre
donc ce qui est super mais du coup on a
des cellules commerciales qui sont pas
toujours adaptés à des grandes marques
qui voudraient s'implanter
donc il faut aussi qu'on travaille c'est
pour ça que sur la poste on avait
travaillé
le centre dauphine il faudrait un jour
qu'on y travaille aussi et puis sur cour
barber buzz pour part bien berne ne pas
offrir aussi des surfaces commerciales
un peu plus grande qu'on est aussi
l'espace ancien de la ville
vous avez prononcé le mot centre
commercial et denis favier souriait en
me voyant à dire ça le la tarte à la
crème habituelle c'est un centre ville
piéton c'est le bonheur des centres
commerciaux et la mort du commerce de
centre c'est vrai mais c'est pas vrai
moi je ne suis pas d'accord donc moi je
considère qu'on a la toison d'or au nord
quand on parle à des dijonnais et des
vieux dijonnais souvent ils ont
l'impression de toute façon bas les gens
vont la toison d'or et vont pas au
centre ville non ça c'est faux voilà
totalement faux je connais plein de
monde en sur la première couronne de
dijon il y à des amoureux du centre
ville ils continuent de venir en
centre-ville de toute façon vous n'avez
pas les mêmes commerces en centre
commercial et en centre ville de dijon
nous sommes moi je considère que la
toison d'or est un atout pour le centre
ville de dijon
parce que c'est un aimant à
consommateurs des zones périphériques
des départements périphériques voire de
plus loin puisque la toison d'or attire
les gens de lausanne mais ensuite nous
le centre ville nous apportons par notre
savoir-faire et par ses 40% et ça je le
maintiens de commerçants indépendants
centre ville que nous avons un
supplément c'est à dire une
complémentarité
il n'y a pas les mêmes commerces en
centre ville que dans les centres
commerciaux
c'est complémentaire alors voilà
quelqu'un qui passe juste juste derrière
nous ça marche dans les villes moyennes
aussi ça ou c'est plus compliqué denis
thuriau qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ça le
centre commercial est ce qu'ils
impactent la vie commerciale locale
nevers a beaucoup zones périphériques
par rapport à sa population mange donc
ont voté dans les champions des mètres
carrés en alimentaire par rapport à moi
je suis d'accord je suis pas là pour
opposer ont essayé de concilier parce
que c'est aussi de l'emploi les zones
périphériques c'est aussi des commerces
par contre c'est aussi aux commerçants
de trouver des activités et des
propositions différentes complémentaire
des niches parfois haut de gamme parfois
moins haut de gamme
et puis travaille sur les commerces
aussi un commerçant sur deux qui les
passionne e-commerce et qu'on le veuille
ou pas idée là donc on essaye de travail
dans un mois que les vitrines de 9
à d'autres associations de commerçants
finances d'ailleurs un poste pour aider
notamment les vitrines à accompagner les
commerçants qui ont peur de lits
commerce mais l'innovation elle est là
il faut pas la fuir donc non les primes
à tiques sont à peu près similaires non
à deux difficultés dans la nièvre en
général c'est la baisse de population
que nous connaît pas dijon et ça il faut
remettre des gens qui habitent pour
consommer et ensuite c'est qu'on a une
zone piétonne qui n'a pas été rénovée
comme beaucoup de choses dans la ville
depuis quarante ans et qui n'est pas
belle et donc j'aurais du mal à le faire
pendant ce mandat si j'ai encore la
confiance de nos versoix je le frapperai
mais il faut la préparer que les
municipales comment ça commence mais
c'est une nécessité mais y avait
beaucoup de choses sur lesquelles on
était et pourquoi je dis ça parce que la
plupart des gens qui viennent en centre
ville piéton ou semi piéton qui pour
nevers je vais refaire une nouvelle voie
sans doute la venue de pierre bérégovoy
faut aussi donner une logique faut
donner un circuit les gens la plupart du
temps quand ils viennent en ville il
vient déjà se promener nu qui viennent
un endroit qui est beau six trous la
même chose que dans des zones
commerciales extérieures qui sont
standardisés ils iront là bas et donc il
faut les attirer autrement il ya la
qualité de vie qu'on a tous les uns les
autres et et et l'offre et l'archaïque
architectural mais il faut de l'offre
complémentaire facilité d'accès de nous
de nouveaux moyens de mobilité aussi sur
lesquels je travaille électrique
notamment on va avoir beaucoup de
changements là dessus voilà il ya des
pistes
heureusement positive est ce que dans ce
que va faire nevers dans le cadre de ses
sept aides du gouvernement il ya des
choses qu'on pas été fait ailleurs que
vous allez tester où vous pourriez nous
je vous évoquez maintenant peut-être que
nathalie koenders ça l'intéresse 1 pour
dijon je vais déjà faire des choses pour
de vrai que j'ai du mal à faire parce
que j'ai pas assez de moyens
je prends le périmètre de sauvegarde
qu'on a voté en conseil municipal ça
fait déjà deux trois ans et notamment
aussi le droit d'exercer ce droit de
préemption par la mairie de racheter des
ddd pas de porte nous voir ce qu'on en
fait de maîtriser le coup parce que
parfois les loyers sont trop chers et ça
c'est on essaie d'avoir une possible
politique d'incitation mais pour
l'appliquer faut des moyens et ça j'en
ai pas assez donc je compte beaucoup sur
le programme action coeur de ville il ya
aussi une piste est intéressante qui est
l'ouverture de surface relevant de la
commission d'aménagement en centre ville
il y aurait plus besoin de passer par ce
qu'on appelle la cdac donc c'est une
façon d'amener des grandes enseignes qui
regardent parfois l'extérieur mais leur
dire la priorité c'est centre ville et
donc c'est pas opposé mais peut-être de
privilégier un coeur de ville pour que
notre territoire compte
de vivre nathalie koenders après la
piétonnisation il ya un autre stade où
où c'est le maximum qu'on peut faire
dans une ville comme dijon il faut
s'arrêter un moment donné oui c'est sûr
qu'on va pas tout piétonniser le coeur
de ville
maintenant on a encore des beaux projets
aussi pour dix jours à venir c'est déjà
l'année prochaine l'ouverture du musée
des beaux-arts rénové qui va de fait
contribue à l'attractivité touristique
de dijon je rappelle que ces trois
millions de visiteurs qui viennent mais
que le musée des beaux-arts est aussi
très fréquenté par les dijonnais et je
pense qu'aussi l'intérêt c'est d'offrir
dans les centres villes des lieux des
espaces culturels ou ouvert aux jeunes
une offre un peu comme on peut voir à
berlin où vous savez pendant toute toute
la journée
et bien vous pouvez faire des activités
des choses comme ça je pense que
vraiment il faut marquer notre
spécificité donc on a encore de beaux
projets si on note camille chevalier le
commerce y va avec forcément tout le
reste c'est à dire la culture ce que
j'avais dire exactement nous nous
travaillons avec l'office du tourisme
avec le pôle tourisme
et puis nous souhaitons aussi travaillé
un peu plus qu'à l'heure actuelle avec
le pôle culture donc entre autres avec
christine martin qui adjointe à la
culture
ces trois entités ne peuvent qu être
intimement imbriqués et c'est pour ça
que quand on va au centre commercial de
la toison d'or au nord de dijon pour
faire de la promotion du centre ville ce
sont ces trois entités qui sont sur
place pour dire venez en centre ville
lyall tram en plus ces douze minutes
entre les deux centres et puis vous
pouvez mêlée à la fois la consommation
au tourisme et à la culture
un mot sur le coup nathalie koenders ça
coûte cher de piétonniser ou pas il ya
parfois cet échange d'un conseil
municipal a dit jean sur les matériaux
utilisés canton piétonniser ce qu'on
prendrait des très belles pierres est ce
qu'on ferait est ce que ça coûte cher
est ce qu'on oublie aussi de faire des
choix c'est à dire on veut que les
tony's et on n'a pas forcément les
moyens de faire des trucs des choses
somptueuses
oui ça a un coût mais ça rapporte
ensuite beaucoup après faut faire des
choix c'est vrai que l'objectif la
piétonnisation à dijon elle est partie
de la piétonnisation de la place de la
libération en 2006 avec l'architecte
bill mott qu'a choisi caractère
programme de 2001 dans les débuts voilà
de la métamorphose du coeur de ville le
choix a été fait un choix minérale parce
que c'était une place royale donc il
faut aussi quand on rénove respecter
l'histoire de notre ville et à dijon il
ya quand même un patrimoine
architectural et une histoire importante
donc il faut pas non plus la mettre de
côté et ensuite eh bien tous construits
en harmonie avec les choix donc
effectivement le choix a été fait sur le
minéral même si quand on prend la place
darcy on a planté des arbres et nous on
souhaite travailler avec les commerçants
avec les unions commerciales c'est ok
elle aussi lp vous avez parlé
d'environnement
vous avez parlé d'environnement et on
piéto nice mais est-ce qu'on fait aussi
revenir du verre à l'intérieur de la
ville est ce que c'est possible quand on
fait ça il faut revégétaliser parmi le
minéral et c'est comme les voitures les
vélos les piétons faut pas opposer non
plus le minéral et végétal mais il faut
l'associer intelligemment donc vous me
demandez tout à l'heure des choses un
peu originale par exemple allez je vais
être énoncées en anglais
deux choses lui être transformé que la
galerie marchande de nos verres ça soit
en aire libre dans le centre-ville dans
ce centre piéton et donc on va mettre
aussi des bornes interactives comme on
trouve dans les grandes galeries
marchandes des capteurs pour le comptage
pour aider les commerçants à savoir
quand est-ce qu'il ouvrait parce qu'il
ya aussi le décalage d'ouverture n'est
du mal à la voir parce que les
franchises parfois voilà donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui peut être assez
innovant dans une ville moyenne vraiment
de d'adapter puis le deuxième concept
qu'on va soutenir pas forcément porter
tout seul mais je peux pas vous en dire
plus pour l'instant comme ça je
reviendrai c'est de dire bah nevers
voilà pendant 45 jours
c'est acté sur une grande enseigne qui
s'implantera peut-être pas la demeure
mais pendant 45 jours vous l'avez elle
vous offre tout dans des boutiques
éphémères dans d autres qu'on va
racheter justement par le droit de
préemption ou avec un partenaire privé
et puis et bien 45 jours plus tard ça
sera axée sur une thématique le pied en
plus des animations qu'on essaye tous de
faire avec nos amis commerçants et
autres associations et sportives et
culturelles
et bien c'est aussi complètement changé
et capté en disant nevers pendant 45
jours c'est ça et puis 45 jours après ça
sera une autre thématique on sait que
c'est une tendance lourde 1 et des
villes comme hambourg qui annonçait tu
veux être la première ville européenne
sans voitures d'ici quelques années
c'est irréversible nathalie koenders
cette idée que les centres villes
les piétons doivent être avec des
transports en commun de votre point de
vue en tout cas de première adjointe à
dijon on reviendra pas en arrière
non mais je rappelle que le centre ville
est accessible aux voitures on a des
parkings souterrains en coeur de ville
on a aussi oui mais il ya un autre
esprit la piétonnisation et génère à
notre esprit notre façon de vivre mais
après c'est vrai qu'on a développé des
navettes gratuites des navettes
électriques pour les gens qui ont des
problèmes de mobilité parce qu'il faut
aussi penser on met en place des
structures de repos des chaises parce
qu'aussi favoriser la marche à pied ce
qui est bon aussi en termes de santé
publique
eh bien il faut aussi penser aux gens
qui peuvent avoir des problèmes de
mobilité et ce soir je pense vraiment
c'est de notre responsabilité aussi de
faire des villes plus écologique plus
durable et de partager mieux l'espace
public entre transports en commun
piétons et voitures
denis favier vous commerçants pour vous
il faut pas revenir en arrière il faut
continuer non mais c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure je pense qu'il
faut tout simplement que on trouve le
juste milieu entre la piétonnisation
j'ai toujours ce discours vous avez des
gens qui sont des irréductibles de la
voiture c'est à dire vous aurez paulhan
raciale et je vais vous coupez denis
favier je vais même pas vous laisser se
développer au torino reste 20 secondes
émission merci à tous les trois hertz
est revenu les battre dimanche prochain
une mission spéciale mai 68 bon dimanche
au revoir et merci
[Musique]